il ne se passe pas une seule journée
sans que les le pouvoir et ses relais
médiatiques ne m'attaque ils me traitent
de tous les noms
mais ne vous méprenez pas le véritable
objet de leur courroux ce n'est pas moi
c'est vous s'il me déteste c'est parce
qu'il vous déteste s'il me méprise c'est
un style vous mais présent contre moi
tout est permis la meute est désormais
lancée à mes trousses mes adversaires
veulent ma mort politique les
journalistes veulent ma mort sociale et
les djihadistes vole ma mort tout court
alors là quelqu'un qui est fans d'eric
zemmour est ce qu'il a réussi son entrée
parce que c'était soit ça ferait entrer
en politique avérée eric zemmour bale et
lennon ben oui parce que on n'a pas été
arrêtée de taxer lui et son équipe
d'amateurs en disant qu'il n'arriverait
pas à fédérer derrière etc et en
quelques jours ils ont changé de ça ils
sont allés à villepinte qu'ils ont
réussi quand même à mobiliser quinze
mille personnes en tout 13 il est
il s'agissait de faire une démonstration
de force en l'occurrence ils ont fait
une démonstration de force après on aime
ou on n'aime pas mais en tout cas ils
ont réussi il a réussi ce qu'il avait
moi je pense beaucoup de choses qu'il
fallait balayer parce que çà çà çà çà
toussotait sa part ça partait mal 16
avec gilles bouleau ça s'est mal passé
etc etc il fallait absolument que ce
meeting là en tout cas ils sont un coup
de poing ce soit fort et à mon sens il a
réussi alors il a plusieurs fois voulu
se défendre contre l'image qui peut
avoir et il a énormément parlé du racine
dire qu'il a dit à chaque fois on
m'accuse d'être raciste des villes y
avait un petit truc aussi va voyons
série ben voyons comment regarder sa
mère insiste alors que
je suis le seul à ne pas confondre la
défense des nôtres avec la haine des
autres
le racisme qu'est ce que c'est c'est
s'imaginer que ceux qui sont différents
de nous sont inférieurs parce qu'ils
sont différents et que ne pourraient
être français que des descendant en
droite ligne de clovis comment
pourrais-je comment pourrais-je penser
cela moi petit juif berbères venus de
l'autre côté de la méditerranée
non évidemment je ne suis pas raciste
non évidemment vous n'êtes pas raciste
tout ce que nous voulons c'est défendre
notre héritage karim il a réussi son
premier jeu tu me mobilise plus de dix
mille personnes dans le contexte il n'y
a pas beaucoup de politiques qui peuvent
le faire moi j'ai rien dit jean-luc n'a
rien de commun avec zemmour c'est jean
luc mélenchon il ajouté
oui il y en avait mille dehors donc qu'
il est à peu près 5000 mais quand même
dix minutes plus de dix mille personnes
et puis est-ce que tu as évoqué tout à
l'heure 2 millions 400 mille personnes
qui le suivent devant la télé ça à
dimanche après midi les stocks les
zemmouris sortie d'une longue séquence
avec le doigt d'honneur marseille l'a
pas vue à marseille et et gilles bouleau
et là il lui fallait réussir ce meeting
et en termes d'organisation a parlé
violente reviendra tout à l'heure il y
avait du monde il a déroulé son
programme avec ses obsessions
immigration islam et identité toujours
pareil et les gens qui étaient là pour
lui était content de quelque part pour
lui c'est une en train campagne réussie